this month marks the 20th anniversary of
first meeting the super talented wack
Packer sour shoes I don't need to go
into the whole history of sour shoes but
the dude sings he plays piano but more
importantly he does amazing Impressions
I've made overtures over the years to
hire him to actually pay him and to you
know be part of the show but you can't
he doesn't want to be on a schedule but
his talented his sour shoes is he can
become um eccentric maybe uh and
disappear for months on end and
sometimes even years and it's been years
we last Saw shower shoes in person when
he was at our studio the week the covet
outbreak hit New York in March 2020. wow
you're talking three years ago we heard
from him again in August of 2020 when he
zoomed into the show from his parents
pull with his keyboard on a pool float
and as usual sour was difficult to
control
the whole keyboard on a full float a
little loading keyboard
oh
[Music]
right right right
[Laughter]
anyway like he's a difficult guy to work
with so after that appearance Sauer
basically cut off all communication with
us Derek what's uh yeah you call him all
the time right I I do I can actually
show you right now what it's like to
call them I have three different phone
numbers for them and they're all blocked
and there's just this message that comes
back immediately that says you know the
party you're trying to reach is yeah you
were trying to reach us not accepting
calls at this time
so he's been claiming for the past three
years that the trees have fallen down
and knocked out the phone lines at his
house like somehow the phone company
hasn't come for three years so wow well
let me give the exciting update now sour
has re-emerged last month he left our
producer Derek a message for the first
time in more than a year hello
[Applause]
[Music]
I miss you
I miss you man have you been all right
quack quack
[Music]
I tell you everything
if I could fix the telephone
there it is an exclusive so these
weren't
voicemails these were voice memos that I
was getting texted to me from a cell
phone I didn't recognize so in other
words his reappearance is as mysterious
as his disappearance I mean nothing is
clear exactly let me play some um
exclusive tape we asked sour why we
haven't been able to reach him on his
house phone and sour answered the
question as former Howard 101 Sports
host Scotty Pharrell
I know I know it's so bizarre with all
trees and wind storms that we have I
mean I'm just reduced now to this
TracFone I mean the connection is just
piss poor
I mean I'm so starving for some good uh
yeah I was like I'm ready to eat the ass
out of a donkey
did that clip did that clear it up for
you now you know there it is sour we
learned has also held down a variety of
part-time jobs we asked if he's working
these days he gave his answer as Richard
Simmons so
yes I am I would say knowing hours a
week at McDonald's
uh a lot of excitement lots of fun lots
of fanfare
uh roughly nine more hours with my
Direct Care Group
um we do a few activities closer to home
now do lots of exercise we move Groove
and lose
[Laughter]
well I try to harness that energy for
our show but he was not having it he
he's one of those guys you can't you
can't direct but he when he directs
himself either he has never made it a
day and when he would come into the
studio and we were in charge of him for
a day or three days you know it's like
trying to lasso a tornado I mean because
he does show up but I miss him his
insanity is what makes him great and yet
his insanity is what holds him back I
gotta get in my car this summer and just
drive up there and see what's happening
up at the house you know it's weird like
as I was doing this update
he's called in twice and then as soon as
the clip stops playing and I go to pick
up the phone he hangs up
four times twice that you saw so at the
the last point we had the call screener
just talking to him trying to hold him
to the last clip but um he's it's for
he's been on the phone four times and
then he gets disconnected whatever the
[__] that means it's like one of those
kidnapping movies where they need to
hold the line for a little while so they
could trace the call we just need to
keep him a little bit longer yeah I was
like oh this is great I'll finish
playing this clip and then I'll pick up
on the real Sour shoes and then he hangs
up Tower if you're listening we would
love to talk to you we love you we miss
you there you go pal all right well
there's your update I think it's a
pretty thorough this is interesting to
find out where sour shoes is in his
Evolution and where he is in his
evolution is exactly where he was like
25 years where we left him yeah right
where we left him nothing changed and we
know very little about it hahaha